yeah so hello everybody good afternoon
uh my name is Inga as it was mentioned
I will be giving a talk
about entitled when a b testing isn't an
option an introduction to quasi
experimental
methods perhaps before we jump into the
topic I will just say a few words about
myself actually I will repeat so
um I'm I currently work as a data
scientist at OLX in Berlin
but my background is in economics and
econometrics so I studied economics and
yeah I started with that basically and
I'm still like at heart I'm an economist
and you will see in the talk why I
mentioned this
so uh without further Ado let us start
and I would like to start by
calling a quote
by Leo bryman
so
in 2001 he published his very famous
paper
about two cultures in statistical
modeling
so basically bryman said that there are
two cultures
in how statistical modeling is used
to reach conclusions from the data and
um
one culture assumes that data is
generated by some stochastic data model
while the other one is most focused on
algorithmic models and treats data
mechanisms as unknown
so that first the first culture is
something that we would label as
economic statistics and econometrics
these days
or at a Days of
bryman
and this agriculture is more something
that we would label machine learning and
these days
so actually bryman he argued that 98 of
statisticians in economic
econometricians follow that first
culture
uh
I this is not true anymore because these
two Fields stay they converge and in for
example in economics
AI methods or have they started to be
incorporated into into research and also
like in machine learning there's some
interest in causality and structural
modeling also like the fact that we're
having this talk today is and evidence
for that
so uh yet about those two cultures
so what what they're about so uh data
modeling culture theory driven
and allows to identify quantities of
Interest like for example treatment
effects
in causal relationships
on the other hand on the other side we
have this algorithmic modeling culture
which is Theory agnostic and purely data
driven
so what it focuses on is prediction
so if so if you follow that algorithmic
modeling culture or machine learning
approach like the main goal is to get
the Y right
right so to have the proper uh to have
the proper prediction and yeah machine
learning models they methods they are
they're set to work really well
if they can make an accurate prediction
on a holdout set this all you need right
so you have a hold of set you have
still good accuracy of your prediction
and that is it so this is like the main
the main focus in contrast to this data
modeling culture when prediction is not
everything so we rather want to
understand how things are modeled uh
what are the forces and how each of it
how each of those forces
shapes the outcome variable
right so more about the process
um yeah and
I said that's in the machine learning
like it's mostly predictive
considerations are taken into account
while causality equilibrium or feedback
effects or not but one might argue that
this is also changing right because
there is there's been so much interest
in recent like years in about model like
explainability interpretability these
things are related
with that first culture
uh or for example there's discussion
about bias and furnace so our our
machine learning models Fair
but this is something that is discussed
past fact so once you have your
prediction you can analyze okay is my
model for or not it's not something that
it's accounted for optimized for on the
go on the contrary to this
um to just say statistics or
econometrics way way of doing so yeah
um so causal inference it's a typical
application of this versatility culture
is causal inference while I'm for for
the other is its prediction problems
so uh
lets me motivate that distinction with
some example
so
um
we yeah so so in economics and also like
um if you use common sense
when you think about prices and demand
you should come to a conclusion that
when prices are increasing then sales or
demand is decreasing right so the high
the higher prices the lower demand or
the lower sales
um that's like not it should be natural
right uh but
um this is not something not something
that is always observed in the data so
in the data sometimes so here is an
example
uh in the scatter plot you can see we
have we have
um we have price and sales which are
positively correlated so in this example
when when when Once price increases
those also increases
this is a bit counter-intuitive but this
is yeah it's seen in many data sets
actually
uh to like better picture it or yeah to
visualize it we can think about about
that example in terms of for example uh
demands for hotel rooms and prices for
hotel rooms so
um when yeah when you're booking a hotel
room you're booking yourself right you
want to go on holidays
or um I don't know on a wedding or attic
to a conference right actually we are at
a conference at the moment so uh you see
that yeah there's basically pricer high
so what's going on with with uh with
availability it turns out that hotels
are full so there's been a lot of sales
so prices are high and sales has also
been high right
um which yeah so if then if if you have
such data and then you try to approach
this let's say you try to understand you
want to understand the relationship
between sales and price so you could fit
try to fit a regression model or any
other model
and what masaki would find out is that
yeah price is positively correlated with
sales or
if you increase the prices sales when
will increase too
um
but yeah it's uh and so here you clearly
see that that's fitted line yes it has a
positive slope right
but that model is wrong and we know that
right by economic theory and that common
sense so what is going on there
so uh what in fact happens is that we
have this third Force so we have
relationship here in this diagram
between price and sales so price
definitely impacts sales but we have
this other Force demand here which
impacts both price and sales
so when there's an increase in in demand
both price goes up and sales goes up and
it causes basically the relationship
between price and sales to be distorted
so with the data we had which we had
which we saw on that scatter plot
it would not so we could not control in
any way for that demand factor which
definitely uh
impacted the picture so in terms of
um
in terms of some nomenclature uh the
demand demand in this case would be a
confounder companion Factor
uh yeah and then sales is our like
outcome variable which we wanted to
understand or predict and then price
would be explanatory variables and yeah
they are basically distorted
so you might ask okay so then how do I
answer that problem how do I understand
if I want to understand how actually
uh price is related to sales or if I
want to like estimate demand
uh demand for for those hotels would I
do the answer is that you would need to
basically change the price to the
general to generate data set that would
um
that could be used uh to understand the
problem you need to change the price but
hold everything else fixed so
in the example which we saw before like
two slides ago so there were some
variation within price but what we
didn't see is that our other factors
that were changing as well so here in
contrast in the setup we want to change
only the price and keep everything else
constant and this is something else into
it didn't have that in the data so
um how that could be how that's how that
program could be approached you may ask
so uh this is like widely known problem
in in economics and economists has been
looking into this for decades if not
more right because it's like basic uh
yeah demand model is the basic the basic
model and you learn it and you're like
not even first semester first perhaps
month of your economics course
uh so um what economists would do they
would build so-called structural models
so these are these are models like you
might think about them like as a set of
equations functions which explicitly
model
um yeah relationships in the data
so they yeah they could for example
account for how uh how how people our
yeah our subjects in the experiment
right how they make this how they
maximize their utility for example right
so they maximize the utility by they
have some preferences about how much
they they're going to pay for for a
given Goods like in this case hotel
prices
hotels and yeah this is something that
you put explicitly in the in in such a
structural structure model
but they're not those models like OKAY
model for demand is not that complex but
once you run into some more uh more
complex scenario the model would also
get way more uh would get giant right so
like solving such a model is not really
easy sometimes and also before you build
a model you need to have a fury
right because you need to like represent
the forces uh which you know what's
what's happening with set of equations
so that's Fury there might be some
contradicting theories for example so
how do you know which theory is right
it's sometimes difficult to say
so is there other solution you may ask
and yes there is that resolution so
which seems perfect so in order to
estimate the estimate the demand curve
you could offer random prices to your
clients
right so you're a business you can do
that
you offer them random prices so
basically you run total yeah
the price is totally independent of all
confining factors right including the
demand so once you collect enough data
you will have a perfect estimate of of
the demand curve that's
sounds amazing but not no
because like if you think about running
such an experiment like it would be
incredibly costly such a business would
go bankrupt and like
them right because there's now like
optimization of any sort of prices so
it's not really an ideal scenario but in
theory it could be them
in general like experimentation
is like gold standard for measuring the
effect of an action and
um so it's widely adopted and induced so
um yeah let's let's have a look into
that so
um
especially in business system Silicon
Valley label for randomized randomized
control trials a b testing right if I
assume like most of you are all heard
about this so the circle so-called
completely randomized designs
and it's an experimentation technique in
which subjects are randomly assigned to
control and treatment to groups
so uh I highlighted here the word
randomly because it's it's key so the
assignment should be really the
assignment of subjects were treated or
should be really random and if we have
random assignments we ensure that
yeah our treatment is not correlated
with any
third variables which yeah
yeah basically both control and
treatment groups they are they are
affected with the same confining
variables so we we can see the
difference between a result of like our
treatment
um yeah so in this so-called potential
outcome framework
um
we Define
average treatment effect as in this uh
as here in the slide so average
treatment effect is expected outcome
given that there was a treatment minus
expected outcome given that there was no
treatment so yeah just difference
between these two expected values
um yeah but that being said even though
AV testing is such a such a great tool
uh it's not always possible to run to to
schedule and to launch an experiment or
to design an experiment
so there there are maybe not number for
a number of factors that might not be
possible so the experiments can be
costly long-lasting unethical or illegal
dirt I'm sure you could say more more
reasons like that so to give some
example like you may think about the
following problem that you want to
understand
what is the effect of being fired
somebody of somebody being fired on
income of that person on future income
of that person
right this is some question to which
Economist would be in which economics
would be really interested
uh but yeah how could how could you
answer that question right how being
fired impacts your overall uh overall
income so you may have that idea that
you could design some experiments
so basically in order to control for all
the factors you would have to assign
subjects to the treatment randomly which
means that you would randomly nominate
people for being fired or not and being
fired it's it's it's a big thing like it
has impact on
you know lives of of those people who
are affected so this sounds unethical
right so perhaps it's not the best idea
to run to run this uh such an experiment
also there's another Factor so
um
such a such an experiment would be
long-lasting because in order to like
truly uh truly understand what's impact
on somebody's impact like maybe lifetime
income or expected or expected income
uh you need to run it for years right so
there are like multiple problems arising
already
right so sometimes it's not possible
there is also like another scenario in
which uh underlying assumptions for
identification cannot be met so
something I talked about before like
randomization right so
um randomization like random assignments
of subjects to treatments is really
crucial and like scenario in which it's
easy to uh or which is perceived like to
say almost perfect for for
uh for possibility of randomization is
like um if you if you run if you have a
website and you want to test some change
on the website right
so it seems like almost perfect because
you can have like a large number of
subjects which are treated or not and
yeah you can monitor them and so on and
so on however even however even in that
setup uh however even in that setup
there are some there might be some
potential problems so for example you
might not be it might not be possible to
totally separate uh users or not
separate
to actually identify a user that's using
more than one channel right so you might
have users that use base some app and
desktop version of your site
and that will bring some distortions
right so
um yeah so basically the same person
might land in two groups in control and
treatment so now depending on the size
of that issue you may have biased
results of your a b testing right
and another like problem which could
arise is dependency between treated
subjects
so this is also something that should be
avoided and it is assumed that treatment
which is imposed on the treated group
does not impact the control at all and
yeah so there should be no and there
should be basically no dependency
between between the groups
so
um
given those problems with uh with uh
with a B testing and experimentation at
all so that was the question
um
is there any other way
or can we can we approach the problem
some other way and the answer is yes
some problems you can so here we are at
we have those quasi-experimental setups
or some call them near experimental
setups or Frameworks so basically it was
quasi experiments they are used to
inspect past events
past events that's important that
resemble laboratory experiments
so and they allowed to discover
treatment effects when randomized
effects were not possible for any
reasons mentioned before
for example
something important to know is that
those the squasy experimental Frameworks
in order to discover treatment effects
and they require some small set of extra
assumptions and this the assumptions
will depend on the framework we will go
through a few of them so you will see
um so yeah but each one of them has some
has some extra assumptions that has to
be made and also important like term
about in identification strategy so how
we approach a problem and what
assumptions you are you should impose or
what you should assume is called
identification strategy and this is
something to think about like when you
have
the problem let's say or the data you
should
you should think okay given the problem
what is my identification what's really
my identification strategy how the
treatment was distributed or
yeah this new experiment uh sorry this
past event how it happened what what
should I follow so
um
yes the first framework that's the first
class experimental framework I would
like to talk about it is difference in
difference framework
it is also known like as sometimes it
referred as parallel Trends design
so
what's the idea here so uh you need to
have
uh two groups still like like in regular
if it does think you need to have two
groups of your subjects control and
treatment group
and it is important that the subjects
are of both both control above and
treatment group they observed before and
after the treatment
so this is key
here in this example you can see that we
had a treatment on November first so
everything that is before before
November that will be our pre-treatment
period and then on the everything on the
right that line it is post treatment
period and also we observe two groups
which in this chart they are separated
so the orange one is control and and the
blue one is sorry that the orange one is
treatment in the blue NS control
right so here here's something happened
so
um as you may see from like or or think
about from the name
there's this parallel trans parallel
trains term
uh what what it means uh it means that
we need to so yeah so just coming those
two assumptions identification strategy
so it means that
um The crucial assumption in this in
this framework is that before the
treatment we as expect that treatment in
control they behave in they behave in
some similar way and in a similar way
here it means that they share the same
Trends so whenever
one is is is let's say growing the other
one should also grow whenever one is
declining the other one should decline
two so they should really share the same
Trend or even it's required that they
should be like moving in parallel
uh right and here I plot like a fitted
regression lines so you can see I think
with just an eye that in the
pre-treatment period and those both
groups there yeah they share really
parallel parallel Trend and then another
assumptions with another assumption
which we make here is that now about the
post treatment period
is that okay if we identify it uh two
groups which are Trends before the
treatment period we assume that they
will also share uh the trend after the
period of course for the treated group
condition like assuming that the tree
the treatment would not have happened so
if there's no treatment we would expect
and we would expect both groups to still
share the same Trend after uh yeah after
this after the treatment date
um yeah so this is like a key key
assumption what is also important to
mention because
um here in this picture like it seems
that the treatment or
yeah the treatment is not supposed to
affect the control group but it seems
that
um for the control group group nothing
really changed in terms of the trends in
the post-treatment
right so
um yeah this looks like single fitted
regression line but it's not necessary
let's let's imagine that it's a bit
different so actually that um here
um the line started to like move
downwards right so this could happen
it's it's not necessarily it would not
necessarily be like effective treatment
but there could have been some other
third factors like confining variables
for example right right which like this
demand which we saw before that would
change uh to change the picture
basically and yeah so in that case we
assume that okay our control behavior of
control changed but we also assume that
in this hypothetical scenario that if
treatment didn't happen then the
treatment group would also change the
slope because they follow
they share parallel Trends right
so yeah disclaimer
um I think I haven't mentioned that one
important property is that even though
they must try the trend they might be on
different levels so level is not a
problem they just need to move in the
same in the same direction
uh so here in this in this church I
picture I I put um
I put basically
um this hypothesis this violent uh
violet
Violet line it's the what hypothetically
uh what what value of of treatment group
would be if it was not treated right so
it sure is basically the same and the
same uh the same trend
as control and it's like
um yeah it it it it it will be one line
so now identification of treatment
effects it's basically graphically it's
it's this different style right so what
was observed minus what would be
observed if treatment did not happen
so yep
uh now you may think like how is the
soul how to like you want to use that
and how can you solve it so uh the
different diff regression uh is given by
like this uh this uh this term which you
see in in the slides right now so uh
yeah so expected value of a subject at
um
is equal to Alpha which denotes a level
of the control group
and then beta D which is the difference
in the levels between treated and
control group
and then beta T which is which handles
the trend
and then the the most interesting one is
interaction between the fact of being in
the treatment group
and the fact of being in the treatment
period in the past treatment period or
not and really what we are interested in
is that gamma coefficient so this is our
this is our effect uh the Sarah causal
causal effect and into interaction term
so I put some example
so so we can see how how this looks like
in like in
in in real life or actually it's not
real live because that example is it's
uh yeah it's generated with some random
processes and assumptions and some noise
so
um yeah so so here just visualization of
how you prepare the data for uh to
estimate such a model so we have this T
and D variable so T is whether it's post
treatment or pre-treatment or
post-treatment period and they denotes
if
the a unit was treated or not in general
and here you can see like some estimate
like output so we have intercept which
is equal to 6.4 and yes you can just
look at the picture so this is level of
the control group so yeah looks correct
and I mean it is correct because I know
how I generated data but also we have
intercepts for DT in our treatment
effect
so
1.61 is our
gamma gamma coefficient
which we want to like look into
now another quasi-experimental design
it's synthetic control
it was like
there was some Buzz about it about that
method it was even by Susan athlete and
Guido invents in one of their their
papers it was mentioned that it's like
the most impo important development in
program evaluation in the last decade so
that's huge right to say something like
that
um
that's so the idea is is quite simple
however beautiful so
uh and I'd like to think about this as
some kind of generalization of the
difference in differences framework so
basically indifference in differences we
had just one group and that one control
group that was supposed to resemble our
treated units our treated group here the
idea is that okay maybe we don't have to
use just one control maybe we can have
more control and somehow
combine them in a way that they
in a better way
resemble our treatment group right so
we don't have to limit ourselves to just
one one control so
um yeah synthetic control what did that
what it requires it involves
construction of
of a weighted combination of groups used
in control
so yeah in other words we want to create
some forged control group
from the the controls which we have and
we want to create it in such a way that
it will resemble our treated group as
much as possible in the pre-treatment in
the pre-treatment period right so
um any basically any any weighted
combination of the controls you have
built in such a way that it will
resemble
um that it will resemble the group in
the pre-treatment period
so there's obviously so the method or
the idea is is uh is beautiful
that there's obviously like a question
like how do I beat build that synthetic
control
what was the approach like there are
some like in the in the most basic setup
you just may try to like run some
let's say
um
you might try you may try to regress
basically your controls on the on the
treatment group and then see if it works
you can use some regularization if
needed but yeah there are some other
techniques but this is like out of the
scope of of the talk uh of this talk
so here is like uh it's it's
[Music]
um
I show basically
my treatment group and then my created
control group so you can see that in the
pre-treatment my treatment in control
they are almost identical so actually
it's it's too good to be true uh the
system yeah this is due to how I created
the data in in real life this rarely
happens uh it rarely happens because
yeah if if you have perfect fit
right so you would just just assume that
you have overfitting problem and then
you will have your you your synthetic
control in the post treatment periods
would not be really reliable right uh
one thing also about this post-treatment
effect so that
um average treatment the treatment
effects are basically the difference
between synthetic control and treatment
so this is how you how you estimate
the treatment effect in that setup
in this case like the treatment the
defect is really close to zero so yeah
perfect example
um one more one more framework which I
wanted to uh which I want to discuss is
regression discontinuity so in this
framework that treatment is being
decided based on some thresholds
so
here I use example from a book from
different from mataris book business
data science
and we have an example of a design where
um yeah where basically units with value
of some feature which was before which
was above zero were
um
we're in one group and then uh
and then
um basically units which had a lower
value of that feature were were in the
other group right so
um there are some assumptions being made
around that setup and that is basically
about that individuals need a threshold
regardless of their position and they
are considered equivalent so basically
so here we have the data so we assume
that individuals like around here and
here they are very similar right and
yeah but basically they share the same
the same features
um so yeah and that's I didn't say that
that
um that that feature that variable which
dictates the treatment is called running
running variable
[Music]
um
we also have this continuity assumption
so uh basically it means that if we
change this threshold a bit then uh
individuals switching the group would
behave similarly to their new group
right so it's it's an assumption about
the fact that really treatment
affects affects the behavior and yeah uh
the estimated effect so in order to
estimate effects you basically need to
take a difference around uh difference
between groups around that treated
around the treated around the threshold
right and there are some ways that
matters to do that but
um it's it's outside of the outside of
the scope and yeah the estimated effects
are basically the local average
treatment effects so they're only local
this is important they should not be
extrapolated to other
to other values of the threshold so it's
the end of the talk I just wanted to
um I hope I gave you some overview of of
the Quasi experimentary methods at like
I just would like to as as a summary say
that uh yeah what I wanted to like uh
tell to you that is that remember that
prediction are in society are not
necessarily the same and there's cliche
saying that correlation does not imply
causation is actually uh yeah it's
actually important and
yeah remember to consider that
um
thank you
thank you so much Inga for shedding some
light on what we data scientists can do
when we don't have the opportunity to do
a b testing so we received a couple of
questions and I'm starting with the
first one so our quality experiments the
same as so-called natural experiments
and not necessarily like
um so natural experiments like
um of course like um when there's when
there's a natural experiment it might be
it might be analyzed with one of the
Quasi experiment experimental Frameworks
so for example for synthetic control I
can give some quick example right there
is this actually we were in Berlin but
um
there was this case about
um like Germany being unified right so
one would could ask a question like okay
what um
what GDP of West Germany would be if not
the unification right and this is some
kind of a question which you can analyze
with synthetic control for example
actually this is the example that
synthetic control was introduced with so
yeah
thank you a lot for clarifying this
so the next one how do you decide
whether diff or synthetic control group
is more suitable for a given task
so
um with different diff it's probably
because you need to have parallel Trends
so if you do not have parallel Trends
between your control and treatment you
should not use different deaf estimator
as simple as that so you need to check
for for assumptions basically and for
synthetic control it's all about
building
building search away hood combination of
controls that will depict well treated
group in the pre-treatment period so
you have you can validate that
and a little bit adding to this if div
and diff regression assumes that the
post-treatment trend has to be parallel
How would one handle possible long-term
effects of the treatment
like
perhaps
um
[Music]
yeah
like like maybe this diff and diff
should not be used for long term for for
real long-term effects it's more like
local estimation I would say but uh yeah
I'm not sure maybe if that person that
ask wants to clarify or
yeah
that's right
yes and the second one I think it goes
in a very similar Direction and I think
you already answered it so diff and diff
uh regression we assume the relationship
is linear
is linear yeah the trends or yes yes so
and I'm not sure if this was the intent
of the question but in theory could one
also model I don't know like quadratic
so so actually
um
so actually like when you think when you
think about how data looks like like
um right so you may see some like for
example seasonality it can handle
seasonality but it's so so if you have
like seasonal data like for example
weekly Trends right so you analyze
um some some some some feature which
which has weekly trend
which like if you look at uh if you like
plot that variable then perhaps it will
not be like linear as a single line but
yeah as long as the two series are
moving in the same direction it can
handle that
okay thank you so much
um
yeah maybe one last question so is there
some way to mimic the a b testing if
there are no events in the past
resembling the treatment
tricky one
repeat the question um yes um so
um let's assume you want to a B test
something but you don't have any data
from the past that could actually
resemble the treatment
so like I'm not sure how do I run maybe
test if I don't have like I don't know
like like uh how can I analyze something
if if I don't have
data
yeah
okay thank you a lot
um time is up I have one uh quick
announcement
so please if you signed up for the
evening social activity don't get your a
batch like right before the event that
it will be very cute and crowded but try
to get it sometime now maybe in half an
hour or so
um so there won't be such a long queue
yeah with that thanks a lot Inga for
shedding on light on
[Applause]